[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 hoy les proponemos una especie de
viaje para recuperar las sensaciones que
se nos han olvidado durante la pandemia
de coronavirus rememorar sensaciones
como la de los besos el tacto el aliento
y lo haremos a través de un recorrido
por la literatura el arte el cine y la
música con el universo del escritor
argentina edgardo scott y su último
libro contacto muchísimas gracias
edgardo por estar con nosotros la
invitación hoy y primero de todo pues
muchas felicidades porque el libro se
publicó hace muy poquito y ya va por la
segunda edición sí la verdad que yo fui
el primero asombrado cuando me lo dijo
el editor
porque salió y bueno anduvo muy bien y
entonces hubo que reimprimir así que si
en la segunda edición ahora el próximo
vendrá con un circulito que dice 2a
édgar 2 cuando nació en lanús en
argentina-1978 lleva publicados 8 libros
novelas relatos ensayos entre los que
destacan el exceso luto caminantes y los
dos últimos cassette virgen que son
relatos autobiográficos y contacto del
que enseguida hablaremos ese escritor
músico psicoanalista traductor del
inglés y el francés si colabora con
artículos críticos en diferentes medios
en latinoamérica y en europa
contacto es una especie de ensayo en
torno a estos gestos perdidos en que las
medidas de distanciamiento físico
impuestas durante la pandemia pues nos
han robado no gestos que hemos dejado de
hacer y que no sé si algún día podremos
recuperar cuando dice bueno yo tengo que
escribir sobre esto bueno fue durante el
primer confinamiento obviamente yo
siempre digo que
la pandemia y los efectos de la pandemia
en algún momento nos alcanzaron de
manera personal a todo el mundo en algún
momento le pegó la pandemia y en mi caso
fue muy inmediato y fue en el momento
del primer confinamiento porque me
sentía como un poco un león enjaulado
digamos yo soy de justamente de salir
diríamos de
exteriores no soy de la casa digamos
entonces verdaderamente me veía como muy
restringido y por otro lado venía de
traducir de terminar una traducción un
trabajo muy grande que fue traducir
dublineses de joyce de traducir diríamos
la última versión que en castellano
salió el año pasado y eso fue un trabajo
monumental cerrar esa traducción
entonces quería se juntaba como esa
necesidad de descargar las condiciones
absolutamente inéditas en las que
estábamos viviendo
cierto desconcierto cierto miedo también
y bueno siempre como la literatura para
los que escribimos es como un antídoto
contra todos los males de este mundo y
bueno me puse uno es una apuesta muy
erudita hay que decirlo en la que a
partir de un gesto perdido hace
conexiones a veces improbables y al
mismo tiempo muy bien encontradas por
ejemplo la parte del beso hace un viaje
en su universo en el que saltamos de una
de las fotos más famosas de la historia
lo desde de l'hotel de ville de agobia
guano e íbamos a un disco de blues cinta
que explíquenos esa esa conexión
supongo que será un poco la fatalidad de
la asociación libre no que como sabes yo
soy psicoanalista también entonces hay
algo de esa estética diríamos no así
medio random también no musical que
siempre tengo presente hay un chico que
ahora leyó el libro y me decía como que
yo pegaba siempre un volantazo no
digamos como que de golpe iba por un
lado de golpe iba para el otro no
a veces ópera por contraste y demás pero
también tiene que ver cómo mis
curiosidades no creo ser como bastante
más que erudito diría yo curioso
entonces me muevo siempre por distintas
cosas que me interesan y en general
escribir ensayo también me permite ser
fragmentario cómo tratar de unir una
idea cierta representación y decir eso y
listo no hay un trabajo de documentación
no son los cajones
fue como puso flavia y en la en la
contratapa como que uno se vale sus
recuerdos de sus conexiones habla de lo
que puede evocar un beso para usted
y también en el imaginario colectivo la
literatura y nos damos cuenta de que
durante estos meses nos ha privado de
besos y tal vez los de la pasión el beso
de la pasión de pareja no no hayan sido
los más importantes sino esos besos por
ejemplo para despedirse de alguien no
voy a voy a leer un pequeño fragmento
tal vez la infamia la vergüenza más
grande de ésta epidemia y ha sido no
despedir como corresponde a sus muertos
no te vayas dejando mi cuerpo sin llorar
lo ni enterrarlo dice la odisea y no se
equivoca poder darle el último beso el
verdadero beso del adiós el que se da a
la carne muerta fría y amarilla el beso
en la frente seca con ojos marchitos
efectivamente ha habido millones de
casos no de personas que no han podido
despedirse de sus seres queridos en el
lecho de muerte en la muerte
y ya en la odisea usted dice que eso era
importante lo dice que es una de las
bases no es como la una de las piedras
angulares de la duda y occidental
efectivamente una de nuestras biblias
hemos perdido con esta pandemia una
parte de nuestras piedras angulares de
delphi débiles yo creo que como se
cuando decían lo de la muerte cuando
evocaba este fragmento lo veníamos
perdiendo no hay un montón de cosas que
me parece que digamos la pandemia se
encargó de catalizar como se dice pero
había un montón de las eps ya era algo
que ya venía por ejemplo no
y la relación con la muerte de occidente
de un libro magnífico de filipino de
hace muchos años que ya trataba un poco
esto digo esta idea de qué
todos los ritos sociales que antes tenía
la muerte fueron desapareciendo o se
fueron comprimiendo se fueron por
supuesto comercializando hasta llegar un
poco a lo que es hoy que es como si
fuera fuéramos como descartes en
determinado momento y nadie quisiera
saber nada mucho con ese rito no no hay
ritos funerarios y creo que solo en la
pandemia fue vergonzoso me parece que es
como una de las mayores infamias de la
pandemia no si es como develar a un
muerto con gente llorando alrededor a
ver a muertos en bolsas de plástico no
vemos también y todavía en por ejemplo
en argentina todavía pasa no el no
acceso de los familiares a los hostales
cuidar de sus enfermos un montón de
cosas que estuvieron muy mal yo para los
que vivimos afuera el hecho de que no
pudiéramos viajar muchas veces que se
cerraron fronteras cuando era una
situación global bueno
hablando de asepsia
en la parte de cuando habla de la saliva
me ha interesado una parte en la que
dice estamos en la era de la química en
la era de la composición de las cosas y
no de las cosas en sí un nuevo
esencialismo una era neo medieval porque
estamos en una era neo medieval claro
porque bueno por un montón de motivos
por un montón de motivos entre los
cuales paradójicamente en la era en una
era tan cientificista en paralelo
tenemos un montón de discursos que son
absolutamente paralelos a la ciencia y
que van contra la ciencia por un lado no
y después me parece que lo de la química
también va porque viste que hoy es muy
habitual hablar y escuchar a la gente
que dice comemos harinas comemos azúcar
goma algo que hace 30 años era
impensable no 1 comida no se asan una
media luna tal comida digamos uno no
hablaba de la composición de lo que
comía eso después se fue generando algún
modo en el discurso en la parte de los
abrazos porque ha elegido el boxeo para
hablar de los abrazos bueno porque en
principio me pareció que era como muy
evidente no él y además porque en el
boxeo durante durante el confinamiento
yo pensaba bueno qué va a pasar si esto
verdaderamente
termina como de limitar a fuego el
contacto qué va a pasar con todas las
cosas que tienen altos contactos de
algún modo no hay un capítulo que no
puse que iba a ser sobre el casino por
ejemplo
lo que vamos a hacer es limpiar las
fichas del casino todo el tiempo y
entonces pensé en el boxeo por los
boxeadores están todo el tiempo el uno
contra el otro pero también muy cercanos
por eso si te la pelea de forma ni y ali
mítica donde se están abrazando en
realidad todo el tiempo
en un momento en el libro también habla
del grupo de rock francés no agresivo
y rescata bueno una parte de una canción
que habla de la caricia y la metralla y
dice francia me acarició y me ametralló
varias veces lo siga haciendo todavía
quedan cinco años acaba de cumplir cinco
años en francia sí sí sí estoy
celebrando o conmemorando mis cinco años
sí bueno donde uno vive es así digamos
no sea la diferencia quizás es que acá
soy un extranjero entonces también pasa
eso yo siempre digo que hace poco lo
dije en ese texto no que en argentino no
tienen mil problemas en francia tengo
uno solo soy extranjeros no es como un
poco así no ha influido en algo vivir en
francia le ha cambiado la forma de
escribir de qué manera le han olvidado
la forma de vivir y cambia la vida
cambia todo digamos así que sí
de hecho ahora por ejemplo que quiero
encarar una novela más grande digamos y
de ficción bueno eso me requiere un
cierto tiempo que por el momento no
tengo y que quizá escribir ensayo por
ejemplo y fragmentos y bueno se acomodó
mejor a estos primeros años es bueno no
sólo esa actualidad por este maravilloso
libro que es contacto sino que también
ha escrito ha publicado hace poco casete
virgen
y también esa actualidad en italia
porque se ha traducido su novela luto
para mí es una especie de western urbano
no en el que el protagonista se ve
atrapado no en sus propias miserias en
un espacio muy reducido una calle con
siempre los mismos personajes una calle
principal y efectivamente
y cómo ha sido la acogida en en italia
de luto fue muy auspiciosa fue hubo
refería yo digo un poco para cargar a
los argentinos mejores que en argentina
no porque fueran favorables sino porque
verdaderamente hicieron una lectura muy
muy exhaustiva de la novela muy
interesada de la novela yo supongo que
también en europa están muy
acostumbrados a que venga de argentina
el tema de la dictadura para decirlo
rápidamente no y esta novela trata sobre
la actualidad de algún modo y sobre uno
de los principales problemas digamos de
cualquier sociedad latinoamericana
actual que la inseguridad diríamos lo
que se llama se denomina mediáticamente
la inseguridad el tema de que te roben
de la paranoia respecto de que te roben
bueno la violencia social y violencia
económica entonces como me parece que
eso lo sorprendió un poco a los tanos y
no sólo esa actualidad por eso hay un
proyecto en marcha también en torno a
esta novela porque se va a llevar a la
gran pantalla explica nos estamos
escribiendo el guión estamos en ese
nivel pero muy muy entusiasmados con un
director ya amigo que se llama néstor
correa que ha hecho dos documentales
extraordinarios sobre figuras del rock y
documentales muy muy buenos y nos
conocimos a través de una amiga y
cantante gabriela un mito del rock
argentino y bueno nos conectó y los dos
somos del suburbio y entonces él leyó la
novela le encantó se enganchó le pareció
muy cinematográfica como se suele decir
un lugar común de la crítica
y nos pusimos a trabajar y en encajamos
muy bien así que estamos trabajando y yo
estoy aprendiendo un montón pues la
primera vez que escribí un guión para
cine así que también está bueno eso
bueno pues edgardo de escotes le
deseamos mucha suerte y mucho éxito con
todos estos proyectos y también con este
último libro contacto que acaba de
publicar y bueno tendremos que invitar
otra vez porque 'no no sé pero
muchísimas gracias y muchísimas gracias
a todos ustedes por habernos acompañado
ya saben que nos pueden seguir por
internet en rf y mundo.com bien france24
puntocom hasta pronto amigos
[Música]